unser selbstgemachtes fast food menü
mitbürger mit cola mit pommes
herzlich willkommen zu machen heutigen
video leute ich hab vor geraumer zeit
mal japanische süßigkeiten getestet die
man sich selbst zusammen mit 2000 süßes
sushi set und ich habe genau das gleiche
prinzip als burger pommes und cola
gefunden
tja und was hier steht aber in dieser
packenden befindet sich pulver formen
und sonstwas um dieses tablett hierher
zu stellt das heißt hier drin findet
sich cora pulver pulver und paulus
pulver und immer eine so was gibt es
einfach nicht in deutschland hat das in
einem japanischen supermarkt gefunden im
asiatischen viertel in düsseldorf und
ich würde sagen wir packen das einfach
mal aus also ja leute wollen wie man
testen ob es funktioniert schauen was
hier drin ist und einfach aufmachen dann
machen wir hier mal auf hier ist die
öffnung der verpackung da sieht man
sogar das was ich letztes mal gemacht
habe also sohn bären und so mini donuts
das kann natürlich gerne nochmal
verlinken unten und wir packen mal aus
das ist wieder so klassisch als sie
haben zwischen fand ich das gefühl die
haben aber bei sturm bekenne challenge
gemacht und es war wirklich die sache
ist war verpackt und da war es nochmal
verpackt und teilweise waren die sachen
noch ein drittes mal verpackt klostersee
ihr seht schon gehört die verpackung zum
design das heißt wir eröffnen das hier
ganz vorsichtig und ziehen uns mal raus
und wie zu erwarten jede menge pulver
und so ein mini messe formen und sonst
was mit dem wir das hier zubereiten
können vom prinzip her ist das so viel
dass jetzt mal das vorsichtig ich habe
echt schiss was kaputt zu machen weil
ich hab zwar gage meckert hier mit
doppelter verpacken aber immerhin
benutzt man die vertrag
hier nochmal alles fachleute das wäre
ausgepackt ich schneide das jetzt mal
eben aus okay leute wir haben bisschen
ausgeschnitten wird sagen wir machen
erstmal den cola welcher halb fertig
wird beworben den kleinen streifen
tesafilm leute dann nehmen wir uns zum
kleinen streifen tesafilm haben gleich
unseren kohle welcher schon mal fertig
gemacht aber hier sieht man schon mal
ein perfekter mini cola becher so die
anleitung steht hier hinten drauf und
alle erstes müssen wir dieses förmchen
hier zurecht schneiden
also man muss relativ viel schneiden
hier das ding ist das ist glaube ich für
kids eigentlich und es ist so eine
kombination aus so einem bastel spiel
mit essen also man bastelt sich so eine
süßigkeit was sie eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht finde also man muss halt
erstmal was was machen um sich das süße
super die bz ich glaube in dem fall wird
es sogar herzhaft große frage ist was
ist in diesen mythischen prüfen
das ist wirklich die frage wie macht man
das hier steht jetzt drin
wir nehmen dieses und fügen den blauen
beutel in
erst mal alle beutel geöffnet also wir
nehmen die gelbe mischung und füllen sie
hier hinein nicht wie so ein hart für
mich niedrig man aber hat nichts mit
pommes ja das ist einfach ein bisschen
religiös weil wir schütten 23 ist und
ganz feines pulver
sie sollen dem pulver zwei von den
wasser käppchen das ist dieses kleine
häppchen hier was ich tat abgestritten
hinzufügen damit und jetzt steht hier
umrühren mit dem löffel also wir rühren
dass jetzt einfach mal ganz fleißig um
und es verändert die konsistenz und wie
wird jetzt so drei irgendwie die
konsistenz wird jetzt auch so ganz ja
sowieso relativ hart und jetzt nehmen
wir das hier und müssen das zu einer
ebenen masse hier drin form eine ebene
mache hier damit dass auch gutes
resultat wird am ende so ist es einfach
der hoerbiger geht's nach dem gesicht
des kartoffel ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich ist das ist kein scherz
ist wirklich nicht probieren wir packen
das kürzen der mikrowelle
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was hier
steht wie lange wie viel watt wo sind
müssen wir erwarten hier oben steht 500
watt 40 sekunden fertig gucken ist
plastik geschmolzen nein aber also wow
das sieht richtig knusprig aus aber
meine pommes sind ein bisschen lange
drin gewesen
es ist so krank wie willst es riecht
nach pommes ist fühlt sich an wie
frittierte pommes für meine ab wie man
drauf das wird wahrscheinlich locker so
richtig krank
erst mal freunde bevor wir hier das
essengehen machen wir mal unsere pommes
tütet werde hier wohl das jetzt mal war
aus st
das ist unsere masse becker ich lerne
immer so rum liegen weil so guck mal das
hat sogar so eine kleine pommes vorn
das ist ja so gerät fehlt jetzt
schneiden wir das hier mal natürlich mit
dem beiliegen
mini messer ich glaube genauso war es
vorgesehen und da schaut man hierher
leute als nächstes geht es also an dass
bürger partie also die bulette sozusagen
dafür mischen wir wieder zwei karten
wasser nimmt fleisch pulver ich bin mal
gespannt wie das ja mal sehen wie das
pulver hier aussieht es ist einfach so
wie so eine mischung aus salz und
nirgendwo von der konsistenz natürlich
noch teils des trinkwasser genommen um
die besten resultate zu erzielen
das riecht nach so einer deutschen
frikadelle alter nach mass und dass ich
mich fast wie dicke das gab michael
hatten weil das geht nicht dass das
pulver erwischt dann verkommt das ist
hier ein damit es natürlich auch die
bestmögliche plattform erhält wir müssen
jetzt erst mal das brötchen pulver an
und packenden die brötchen sowie das
hätte auch in die mikrowelle und die
sache ist wir haben ja schon gesehen es
gibt zwei unterschiedliche was zahlen
und wahrscheinlich war eine warze für
die pommes und die andere bezahlen
für den rest hier steht dass man das
nicht auf die drehs für tun sondern
mittig platzierten wahrscheinlich dass
halt eben nicht ein punkt anderen
nächste mal ein bisschen besser gucken
aber ich dachte mir so japanische
verpackungen lukas teekanne anders
versteht jetzt bildet wieder hier
vermischt
ich glaube jeder von euch eine bäckerei
eine besichtigung gemacht hat weiß dass
das deutsche brot genauso zubereitet
wird dann mischt einfach wasser mit
einem haufen pulver und dann entsteht
das gute deutsche wagenrad brot so
deutet hier ist die verpackung wir
werden es jetzt besser machen als beim
ersten mal vielleicht gucke ich auch
zwischendurch mal rein und wir hatten
wieder die mikrowelle
wie sieht es hier drin das ding alter
schwede kommt man sieht richtig hier an
den poren dass es so gebacken ist aber
dass drüben das noch nicht fertig das
heißt wir müssen uns jetzt nochmal rein
tun ich drehe es einfach mal
weil es auf der einen seite schneller
hingesetzt gucken wir rein ja beide sind
fertig gutermuth als nächstes werden wir
einen blick auf unsere geliebte
verpackung machen wir den käse eine
kappe wasser mit der gelben mischung auf
diese vorgesehenen folie hier soll man
erst mal den käse platt drücken und
jetzt haben wir zwei scheiben käse und
freunde mir ist aufgefallen es könnte
genauso gut jede andere asiatische
kultur sein aber ich habe nichts
falsches gesagt und das ist wirklich
japanisch als nächstes leute catcher
haben wir unsere ketchup wie es jetzt
fertig und jetzt geht es daran unser
essen zu präparieren platzieren wie
einfach mal hier unsere unterseiten
unsere oberseite liegen im bürgerladen
und schneiden auch das partie in der
mitte auseinander und das legen jetzt
einmal hier drauf hat die perfekte
breite als nächstes unsere scheibe käse
sie zum fall muss ich sagen dass ich als
nächstes kommt unsere catch as catch up
ist oben drauf unser art lee berger ist
jetzt auch fertig da ist es bleibt noch
eine sache coca cola aus dem beutel wir
öffnen die letzte verpackung das schon
es scheint so dass ich hier nach cola
und ich still locker war wieder das
richtige nicola freundin
ich darf euch präsentieren unser
selbstgemachtes fast food menü mitbürger
mit cola mit pommes js
[Musik]
leute ich bin jetzt wirklich mehr als
gespannt wie das ganze er schmeckt womit
soll ich anfangen die pommes oder ist
der beste ich weiß nicht was du durst
das wird mich mein durchs stillen sind
der nun getötete ja ungefähr drei der
cholera also wir uns mit coca-cola
beginnen wir risiko dar
ich probiere mal denke das hat
kohlensäure
sie hat das kohle wie schmeckt wie eine
salz regel cola wahrscheinlich weiß für
kids ist eigentlich deshalb keinen
zucker oder so was wir dass das internet
ist aber köstlich ein stück schinken
kommen beim nächsten stück ist der laden
hier auch dann leer
probieren wir als nächstes eine unserer
promis welche nehmen wir die dem
kommissar texten ist die hier eine
pommes boersego.de die habsburger diesen
fast food artigen geschmack werden was
das ist
die pommes sind sogar nur sprit und ich
habe sie nicht richtig zubereitet und
sie schmecken gut sie schmecken die
kommen ist leute was ist das für eine
magie kommission aufgegessen habe immer
noch ein bisschen hunger fast satt aber
nehmen wir also als nächstes timpe seid
ihr bereit dafür dass ich einen
businessmann nehmen 32 ein
schmeckt es richtig oder leute das ist
einfach ein herzhafter bürger aus pulver
es schmeckt ein bisschen komisch aber es
ist ein herzhafter bürger aus pulver und
er schmeckt nicht mal wirklich schlecht
also zweiter bis das ding ist wenn ich
diesen bürger blind bekommen hätte augen
verbunden und hätten nicht gewusst das
ist das gibt hätte ich wahrscheinlich
gesagt das ist jetzt nicht die beste
aber es ist einfach ein kalter burger
das ist so komisch zweiter burger leute
verbal hat immer noch hunger was soll
ich sagen ich fühle mich echt irgendwie
ein bisschen so als hätte ich das buch
gelesen was gibt es für sachen leute
wenn ihr noch mehr solcher coolen sachen
sehen wollt auf einem kanal gibt es
häufiger solche coolen sachen deshalb
abonniert nass gerne leichter
das war es dann auch im heutigen videos
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn das
so ist
ihr wisst und bis zum nächsten mal